It was a lot less secure than we all seem to assume it is, but very few people actually know that.
And we sort of feel like those people that are, you know, in front of the board with all the string attached being like crazy, like it's vulnerable.
And it's like, nobody cares out there because their business is continuing to operate.
And they're like, why would I pay, you know, millions of dollars in running a security program when I continue to operate just fine?
And, you know, I have no service outages and I make all this revenue, like whatever.
Right.
I have a $5 million fine.
It doesn't cost millions to run a bug bounty program.
Most mostly pick up a hundred thousand.
And if I promise if if your bug bounty program burns $50,000 in the first two months, you got bigger problems.
Sure.
And that's exactly it is.
You got bigger problems is usually where you are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put a little money in your bug bounty program.
And if it disappears fast, uh-oh.
That's the curse.
Go make other investments, right?
Go make other investments.